[Music]
hello
this is nicolas the deep chain lead at
insta dip
hi i'm martin i'm bioinformatics leader
in stadium
we are here
at insta deep headquarters in london to
tell you more about this exciting
platform
so
what is deep chain deep chain is our
platform for protein design
given a complex you are working on deep
chain will deliver insights based on
state-of-the-art biophysics and
machine learning and models
so what does deep chain actually do
well deep chain is essentially three
things
it is a scorer mechanism so we take
simulations we take a neural network
strain on millions or billions of amino
acids to give a score for a given pose
or
sequence and but it's also a very
powerful optimizer we use methods like
reinforcement learning optimization or
evolutionary algorithms to find the best
mutation that optimizes your structure
and finally is a platform where you can
really leverage the power and the
insights of
language models trends and millions and
billions of proteins
to help you with a protein design task
there are plenty of methods available
online to perform bioinformatics tasks
what sets deep chain apart
well deep chain is different from what
you have seen so far diptrain has a
first principles-based macromolecular
simulator
which uses not only biophysics but also
augmented with state-of-the-art machine
learning
it
has
it gives you a possibility for
independent verification of your
centric
hypothesis
and it gives you infinite expansion
capabilities that we'll talk about in
just a moment if i'm an experimentalist
with no real computer science background
what better
can i get from deep chain well you're in
luck because you're exactly the person
that we designed deep train for
deep train allows you to tackle
complex biological problems without
having to know anything about
optimization simulations machine
learning will make state-of-the-art
tools available to you at the click of a
button
with reasonable defaults in such a way
that we know that the results that you
get will be meaningful
and not only meaningful they will be
interpretable they will
they'll inform your future experiments
and
if you really are opposed to the
computational methods it's really a
click and forget approach
and that will give you your next figure
next
plot next
data set for the upcoming paper
you can
start uploading your pdb file this can
be a file available locally in your
computer or any protein databank id
available on a pdb
and with that pdb file that would
represent the complex
we can select some positions using deep
chain user interface and optimize them
by the use of the ai designer
the ai designer will start replacing the
residues in the selected positions
until
the binding stability or any criteria of
your choice gets optimized
this is the magic of deep chain you are
deciding your own criteria
but also you can use the deep chain
playground this is leveraging language
models that can identify
high function regions in your protein
just by looking at the protein sequence
now i would like to show you a bit how
deep chain looks i am in the landing
page at deepchain.bio
where we explain a bit of the three main
modules that we described during the
talk and how does it work
once you log in and by the way login is
for free what you will see
is for any
project that you can create
a 3d window where you can see
essentially any structure that you
download from the protein databank or a
local pvp file that you would like to
upload
for this demo we can
create a new design where we are going
to download from the protein data bank
600 g which is um the
rvd from the kovid complex with the s2
receptor here in green
on the ai designer
which is one of the modules um
is basically
we can select some of the positions that
we would like to redesign yeah and we
can do this through the
user interface or we can auto select
those positions
for given positions close to the
interface and then run an experiment and
the experiment
essentially
will we need to define
out of these 25
selected positions how many you would
like to mutate let's say we want to
redesign four of them maximum
and we want to launch it for six hours
we can what we want to do is improve
binding because we are maybe redesigning
a therapeutic but we could uh aggregate
binding as well on our energy scholar
and we can use any app available in the
app hub
to use this uh maybe let's select two
apps one that gives us for example
maximizes the likelihood of a sequence
and uh something that for example
um
like reduces or maximizes the
probability of a benign mutation
so
we run this
and what deep chain is gonna do is it's
gonna go and try to find
um this um
mutations in these selected positions
that optimize for this criteria that we
selected of course this takes a few
hours so
i can go and have some
i show you some results of already runs
that we launched before and what you see
essentially is a scatter plot with
different features like here we see
stability versus polar contribution but
we would like to see something like
binding
and here we can
look for for mutations coming from deep
chain that score uh quite well on
stability and uh on for example binding
and essentially this is what a deep
chain is proposing and here we can see
some sort of analysis on this
on this proposed mutation
and
this is where
on the ai designer side but we can also
show you the playground and the
playground essentially
as i said it shows a distribution of all
of the amino acids probability for a
given sequence here for example the
spike protein sequence
that we uploaded and
we see that the transformer thinks that
m is highly likely to be metallian in
the the starter amino acid in a sequence
although here the natural one is t
and and
we can put all these probabilities on
top of a 3d structure and this is part
of the playground in the structured
playground and you see here how this
looks and we could identify zones where
the probability of mutation is very low
so there is the wild type scores very
well but some other places where the
probability of mutation is quite quite
high like for example um here
and this is how we hope you will
interact with language models in in 2d
or in in 3d
and last but i know
i mean let me just show you something
else on the playground
which is that you can input any sequence
that you want and here i i have the
ubiquitin sequence yeah yeah
and i can cut it and paste it onto
the
the score i can select the model let's
take a facebook esm model
and we can submit this for
scoring and you can see for example
um the i can also do the same for a
broad bird
yeah and and this is gonna be running on
our server scoring all the probabilities
and hopefully giving you back their
results and you see here again m
is the most likely amino acid but
here is the wild type
and there is a lot more to do with this
and we also see the
likelihood of the sequence and finally
there is the md simulations module again
it takes a bit to run the grommet but
here i have a i have run a few
simulations and i can show you how this
looks like
this is more than a 3d video you can see
here the the potential energy or the
kinetic energy and you see the
trajectory
um but yeah we can change for example
the the representation
and so it's a bit more than than just a
video and of course we can export this
animation and
do a nice plot for
for your research
so that's all in a nutshell of what we
wanted to show about deep chain but hope
you can try it on yourself just find us
a deep chain dot value
thanks
but what if i'm a computational
biologist and i develop my own metals
is deep chain relevant to me right we're
at ismb pretty much everyone here
develops a method or two deep chain has
been developed for people like us
not only it presents a simple user
interface
but also it gives you an almost infinite
customizability
you're able to develop your own software
your own script your own
methods using deep chain
utilizing our fully free api
deep chain
is
fully modular and as such
if you want you can replace
any on or ever a bit of the system
with something that you have a trust in
something that is more suitable for your
own purposes
finally
deep chain starts with a
large ecosystem of apps apps that you
develop and that then can be seamlessly
integrated into deep chain as a platform
so
what are deep chain apps we have been
talking about them
deep chain apps is a collaborative
framework that allows the user to train
neural networks based on protein
sequences
these neural networks can be either
predictors or classifiers and they
become the scorers of deep chain so
given a sequence you can score
things such as immunogenicity or
toxicity of a sequence so
in summary
we can
take our own data calculate the protein
embedding cell with the deep chain and
use that to train a classifier or a
predictor to use as an app
this app will give a score that can be
used to for an optimization run on deep
chain so how can we build an app
well
we got you covered here because we are
open sourcing three repositories
biotransformers who make it very easy to
work with these large language models
biodatasets where we are planning to
collect sequences and sequence
embeddings from a lot of different data
sources and deep chain apps where we
provide the templates that make creating
an app very easy to find out more just
go to our github
deep chain bio they are apache license
so you can use them for anything you
want not just on deep chain well we
talked a lot about ai designer we talked
a lot about language models available on
deep chain playground but deep chain is
more than that there are different
modules such as the md simulation module
where
you can use gromacs as a service
you upload your pdb structure you set
parameters such as temperature and
duration of the simulation and we will
run it on our powerful nvidia a100
infrastructure to get the results back
to you another important feature that we
provide
on deep chain is jupiter notebooks
hosted on deep chain
so you can have all your data in the
same place we are looking forward for
you to test it on deepchain.bio but what
if i don't do protein design
should i care for deep chain at all well
even though [ __ ] has been developed
as a potent design platform it's not
only one thing that it does
what we can do is we can do protein
structure assessment we can you can
upload the pdb file and it will tell you
what's
what's right and what's wrong about it
using our own internal assessment
methodology
you can
in turn do modeling of snips you can see
which polymorphisms have a positive and
negative effect on your search by
default in order to provide the best
possible accuracy and performance
tradeoff in deep chain we focus on the
amino acid based systems however
within the deep chain app ecosystem
we're able to handle a vast array of
computational biology tasks
and as our simulator is very much
physics based
we're able to accommodate anything that
you may want to simulate so does that
mean that deep chain performs docking
no not really
however
if you do know how
how complex is about to assemble you can
simulate docking
using restraints
and if you don't know how your complex
is
to assemble
you can use our language models to
predict the
the complex
interfaces
another important feature is the pattern
search engine where we can provide
information about
the ip on the sequence that deep chain
come up with
[Music]
so why did chain well we all know that
protein in design is a very complex
problem and it can be tackled from
several angles this is what we are
trying to do on deep chain
we are using state-of-the-art biophysics
and thermodynamical models
through simulation and energy potentials
but we are also leveraging cutting-edge
ai such as the transformers trained on
millions of protein sequences
this conglomerate of techniques make a
deep chain a very powerful tool
and we put it in your hands and
accessible to the general biology
community we think it will grow
with the user base and with your
feedback so
help us democratize in science and
putting these very powerful tools in
your hands
join us at deepchain.bio
remember
that deep chain is an evolving product
so we have things like docking and
initial folding in our roadmap thank you
for your attention and i hope that you
enjoyed hearing about deep trend as much
as we enjoyed building it yes remember
to check us out at deepchain.bio or at
our github open source repositories
i hope you enjoy the rest of ismb
you